come on bub bub
move on it's time to move on now the one
I think yeah but this one's so cool what
the hell
uh hope that in there if I wanna take
that out of here I'm gonna just go like
this
I had to put it put it over one leg like
this one Wow high score okay what is
this mouse okay you break my mouse and
keep going a little more just keep going
you're Scott it hey hey I'm sure this
will just go swimmingly
of course well it should only go driving
Lee
look what you just made happen dang I
just laying in all right you at new I'm
using a vehicle that's not so derpy on
this stupid ramps yes exactly that that
all hos that sumbitch I'm never gonna
stay on past these ran you're gonna be
fine you go man that's good you're fine
I'm perfectly fine
well good we didn't it's like on me
doom from the front yeah nice and close
get up there
I just exploded Oh God
I blew him up with my mind you do it
kitty
like we gonna save you what happened
oh there's a sound we're saying this
this wall yes I'm saying that white wall
hit the wall and then you died
I guess I'm yeah yeah look away from it
no nothing said you're fun happening
don't just just wait look no just give
me two minutes
look just just hang on look just give me
two minutes go in through the long time
here well just don't just hang on I'm
doing something no that's pretty good
are you just gonna let me do this to you
oh I can look but oh god yes yes yes no
you need to go slow because it's fooling
them you can swallow you get through
yeah and never see it coming you're
right maybe I'll just like yeah exactly
you creep up on them they're very
startled watch out you're a scarab oh
you scared them
just a tours oh so well mm-hmm so like
back here yes there thank God stay
together
I have apparently made of sticky sticky
oh my god like the train is already
there that's the one that came to hit
you know I'm like I don't know where
something [ __ ] is gonna come over
from there
all right I'm gonna stick with my head
that's sweet shot that's a good shot
just waiting for the destruction to go
over what's going on what did you do
we're gonna do it in first person I
suppose so Wow no you're a startled okay
well everything went better than
expected that's better than last time
oh boy I will get it Oh miss Robert
thank you Robert we didn't seem as naive
oh they are you still here I'll go get
oh you can circle around haha never
think'st ever to circle around the
spinning wheel of death as my to them
let me go everything went better than
expected
oh that's one of my favorites God oh yes
I forgot about ya oh that would make
much more sense I'm gonna win I think
you went too fast oh my god yeah I win
Oh perfect
yes exactly that's spinning I love
spinning round II you can actually get
through this one I swear you can
actually make it it is totally don't
like randomly spawning cars yeah I know
but you can make it through I promise
you you can not with that car probably
but you can make it through with
something small and quick pink oh oh you
were born for that car I'm pretty sure
it's all lucky it's a car because they
leaned down in the hospital gurney so
that you think the key is you guys like
got it right from the get-go so you
don't go do it okay is that a thing
restless leg syndrome
alright go you make it yeah
cat lost your opportunity for the less
cars but I think lay there do one with
the bird I made it through all the way
yes I actually did it was like 10 times
the bird have faith in the herd that car
yeah [ __ ] you car
I bet no I bet if I do once cuz I
actually have hidden bird well alright
see you died in my fat face and bird Bob
loves I've had in the bird
I swear I have video evidence a minute
okay that was turbo dismount with Bob
here thank you all so much for watching
so if you enjoyed this please leave a
like down below on this like I don't
know how much more turbo dismount you
guys could possibly get from me but this
has been amazingly fun so thank you all
so much for watching thanks again Bob
burger was that a real guy I thought it
was like another ten bells like all
right so thanks again for watching as
always we will see you
Oh